- Welcome back to the 1980s
and to my birthday show!
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Thank you everyone who just
surprised me with that video,
that was so sweet!
This is a show where everything
is literally a surprise to me,
even these words I'm
reading right now. (laughs)
I wanted to also say a
big thank you to everyone
who helped us give away
that amazing trip to London.
(audience cheers)
That was so cool.
Shout out to Courtney
Jackson, she is amazing.
- Kelly, I love you, but I
gotta cut you off real quick.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
Happy Birthday!
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
- It's Machine Gun Kelly, you're so nice!
- Hi.
- Oh my gosh.
- You're so nice!
- Thank you.
- You just, you smell good.
- Thanks.
- How are you?
- Um, I woke up 15 minutes ago.
- I love you, that's me.
- I forgot my shoes, so
I'm wearing my house shoes.
(Kelly laughs)
- You're like, "I ran."
That's me getting to,
I still feel like a teenager sometimes,
I will show up in my PJs.
- Yeah, I thought I had, I
thought we weren't, they were-
- You thought you had more time?
- I thought I had more
time, and they were like,
"You have 15 minutes, you
have to get here now."
And then I got in the car-
- This must be an artist thing.
- And they were like where's your shoes?
And I was like, "I don't
have my shoes, but I'm here."
(Kelly laughs)
I actually, so I know it's
your birthday every year
because it's also my birthday.
(audience cheers)
- Wait, what?
I did not remember that.
We have the same birthday?
- Yeah.
- I think we might've talked about that.
- Well my birthday's
today, yours is Sunday.
- Your birthday's just today.
Oh, okay, but you're a Taurus.
- Yeah.
- We're amazing.
(audience cheers)
We're amazing.
Happy birthday!
- Thank you, but-
- That's exciting.
- I didn't just come with my, I didn't-
- So you woke up on your
birthday to, oh that's kind.
- [MGK] No, no, no, it's cool, it's cool.
- Is it? I dunno.
- We've gotta little celebration,
I didn't just bring my slippers out.
- You didn't just bring you slippers.
Okay. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
- So, if you don't mind, I would like to
(yells) hit it, ladies!
- Oh, hit it ladies?
What am I doing?
(uplifting music)
(Mariachi Bonitas singing
in foreign language)
Look at that queso!
(Mariachi Bonitas singing
in foreign language)
♪ We will move forward and
we always make believe ♪
- [Singer] Happy Birthday!
- Oh, thank you, that was so sweet!
You guys are so beautiful.
- Happy birthday.
- Thank you guys, that was so sweet.
Oh my gosh. Thank you.
(audience cheers)
Thank you so much.
Look at this queso!
- Thank you.
- Look at this queso, ladies!
Are we gonna do it?
- [MGK] Yup.
- I've never done this with a,
how have I never done this at a party?
Oh, wow.
(chip crunching)
Do you like queso?
- I love queso so much.
- I love queso!
(singer laughs)
- Y'all wanna chip?
- [Singer] Little piece
of heaven, right here.
- Oh my god, it's so good.
And margaritas?
- Uh-huh.
- All right, come on, Machine Gun Kelly.
- Happy Birthday.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
- Happy Birthday to you!
- Thank you.
- There we go.
Oh my god.
So and you brought the
Mariachi Bonitas, I love this.
Thank you so much for
coming out to the show.
- [Singer] Oh, thank you.
(audience cheers)
- You are so beautiful.
- [Singer] We wouldn't
miss it for the world.
- Just so you know, Snoop
would be so jealous right now,
he loves this music, we
talk about it all the time.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- I like your slippers.
(audience cheers)
Thank you.
- Take some queso
on your way out.
(audience cheers)
Ooh, you can even wrap up
the flour tortilla in it,
I like it, I like it.
- 'Kay, bye everybody,
go back to home base
they told me to tell you.
- Okay.
(audience cheers)
I'm going back to home base.
I love this show.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
I don't know if I was supposed
to bring my margarita,
but I did.
Thank you so much for the
gifts and stopping by,
Happy Birthday!
(audience cheers)
Machine Gun Kelly's latest album,
"Mainstream Sellout" hit
Number One on Billboard.
(imitates air horn)
Get it wherever you get
your music and look for him
out on tour this summer,
that's exciting,
tours are back, y'all.
(audience cheers)